[Musique]
depuis 20 ans le centre scientifique
canadien de santé humaine et animale à
un but protéger la population contre les
maladies infectieuses
une frénésie cave virus du nil chaque
jour les chercheurs tentent de trouver
des façons de mieux les combattre
pour souligner son 20e anniversaire le
centre a ouvert ses portes au public
cela on n'est pas capable de vraiment
démontrer exactement ce qui se passe ici
est donc avoir la chance d'avoir les str
et n'irait pouvoir leur parler et
interagir avec eux répondent à leurs
questions
c'est vraiment une opportunité que tout
le monde travaille ici
le centre se targue d'être le seul dans
le monde qui comprend à la fois des
laboratoires de haute biosécurité
animale et humaine sous le même toit
cela permet de faire des percées dont le
vaccin contre l'ebola créé ici à
winnipeg en 2015
il est 500 scientifiques du centre sont
particulièrement fiers de faire partie
de cette organisation
les visiteurs ont pu découvrir le centre
d'opérations qui peut être utilisé pour
coordonner la réponse à une situation de
crise comme une épidémie
certains amateurs de science c'était une
visite particulièrement attendu je suis
très excité avoir une chance de visiter
un laboratoire comme celui ci arrive
souvent lors des portes ouvertes les
visiteurs ont appris ce qui se passe
dans cet immeuble sécurisé des centaines
de personnes ont pu s'informer il
parlait aux scientifiques des activités
étaient offertes pour instruire et
divertir les plus jeunes est capable de
voir les jeunes les inspirer au type de
travail qu'on fait le type de travail de
travail qui vont pouvoir faire dans le
futur c'est vraiment une chance pour
nous
commencé à cultiver la relève même que
lyon 6 une façon de mieux faire
connaître le centre mais aussi
d'intéresser une future génération de
chercheurs combattre les infections de
l'avenir ici remy autiero du canada à
winnipeg